on this tuesday night hurricane fiona's
ferocity
the devastation and despair in the
caribbean but the important thing is
that we're alive with the storm set to
lash atlantic canada when it could hit
the prime minister's first un general
assembly in four years the
organization's ominous warning a taste
of inflation how pressure on pocketbooks
is changing the way canadians shop for
food and the worldwide outcry after a
woman this could be me this could be my
daughter dies in the custody of iran's
morality police
global national with donna friesen
reporting tonight nitu garcia
good evening and thanks for joining us
ottawa is getting set to drop the
mandatory vaccination requirements for
international travel making the arrive
can app optional the change is slated to
take effect by the end of this month
according to a senior government source
who says the proposal still needs to be
finalized by the prime minister before
it can be officially announced this
comes after months of complaints from
members of the travel and tourism
industries who've said the rules have
impeded business
atlantic canada is bracing for a hit
from a powerful and deadly storm
hurricane fiona is ripping through the
caribbean with its sights set on the
gulf of st lawrence it's forecast to hit
saturday as a downgraded post-tropical
storm fiona has already caused
widespread damage in puerto rico and the
dominican republic and as jackson
prescott reports it's the island nation
of turks and caicos now bearing the
brunt
fiona lashed turks and caicos as a major
category 3 storm after skirting the
dominican republic downing trees
flooding roads and upending lives
it is a disaster says this man we lost
everything here and everything got wet i
am ruined the u.s territory of puerto
rico took the brunt of the damage fiona
moved across the island at a slow crawl
dropping nearly a meter of rain in some
places
the island's fragile power grid
collapsed plunging all 3.2 million
residents into darkness before the storm
even made landfall
most homes are still without clean
running water it could take days to
restore
we're looking for gasoline water ice all
the supplies necessary for getting
through this
puerto rico is still struggling to
recover exactly five years after
hurricane maria devastated the island
leaving an estimated 3 000 dead when
fiona hit thousands of homes were still
covered in blue tarps they just went
through maria
and now again
but the important thing is they were
alive officials insist lessons were
learned and the island was better
prepared we have 10 times the meals in
water we also have three times the
generator support that we then we had
prior to hurricane maria
the worry is what comes next after a
quiet start to hurricane season the
atlantic has awoken with conditions ripe
for storms that rapidly intensify and
maintain their strength as they track
north it's important for us to start
thinking about as a society how can we
better prepare our coastlines for these
changing storms for storms that are
becoming stronger and for storms that
are raining more
fiona's path puts it on course to
intensify as it moves toward bermuda
before taking direct aim at nova scotia
and newfoundland and labrador later this
week where there's potential for more
catastrophic damage
jackson proskow global news
in japan at least four people are dead
from typhoon nan madol one of the worst
storms to hit the country
natmedal triggered record rainfall
mudslides and wind gusts topping 230
kilometers per hour
114 people are injured the huge storm
has now been downgraded to a cyclone but
roughly 140 000 homes are still without
electricity
and in alaska the government is
assessing the damage after an intense
storm pounded a remote area in the west
severe flooding knocked out power and
sent residents fleeing the surf was so
strong it tore some homes off of their
foundations the storm triggered by
remnants of typhoon murbak is also
influencing weather patterns as far away
as california
the house of commons resumed sitting
today with a new leader fronting the
opposition pierre pauliev did not get to
face off with prime minister justin
trudeau who's at the united nations
general assembly but the conservative
leader pushed the liberal government on
tax cuts and affordability our chief
political correspondent david aiken
joins us now and as the new session gets
underway david affordability is also top
of mind for the federal government
well lithu prime minister justin trudeau
last week promised the first order of
business this week would be inflation
relief
and his government was true to its word
tabling two new pieces of legislation as
soon as proceedings got underway this is
what an economy that works for all
canadians looks like this is the
targeted support canadians have been
asking for the two bills do three things
first the government proposes a
temporary doubling of the gst rebate
that could put an extra 234 dollars in
the pockets of 11 million canadians
payments will be automatic second those
eligible for the canada housing benefit
can apply for a one-time top-up of five
hundred dollars that's expected to help
1.8 million canadians ottawa is also
proposing a new dental benefit for kids
under 12 in low-income households
without a dental plan it would be a
first step towards universal national
dental care this benefit could help as
many as 500 000 kids get up to thirteen
hundred dollars but to get it you'll
need to apply with receipts when these
bills come to a vote the ndp is expected
to support the liberals is on us is on
government to step up and give you the
respect and the dignity of being able to
buy your groceries pay your bills and be
able to support your family but a former
conservative leader says the government
is on the wrong track the new measures
proposed by the government will just get
vaporized by continued sustained
inflation
and the new conservative leader urged
the government to cancel proposed
increases to the carbon tax and to ei
and cpp premiums will the government
cancel these tax hikes so that canadians
can afford to eat heat and house
themselves
so there's going to be a political fight
over this which means it could be weeks
and possibly months before these bills
become law letting low-income canadians
access this temporary financial relief
nithu
david aiken in ottawa thanks
after a summer of runaway inflation the
increasing stress on canadian families
budgets is starting to ease slightly
according to statistics canada the
inflation rate cooled slightly to 7
percent in august down from a high of
8.1 percent earlier this summer the
biggest driver was the big drop in gas
prices down 9.6 percent but as ann
gaviola reports canadians are still
going to be paying more at the
supermarket
even with a break at the pumps
sticker shock at the grocery store is
putting the squeeze on household budgets
people are on a tight budget interest
rates are going up so you have basically
you have less income to dedicate to food
no matter what in the past year
inflation has forced three quarters of
us to change our food habits forty
percent focused on wasting less one in
five buying cheaper generic label brands
about twenty percent purchasing
discounted food that's about to expire
they're looking at loyalty programs
they're looking at coupons they're
looking at weekly flyers
apps
to reduce waste one particularly
alarming stat nearly one in four are
buying less food thirty percent of women
say that's how they're coping and that's
really i think a dangerous threshold so
it means that people are changing their
diets they're making dietary compromises
getting a handle on inflation during
normal times can be challenging but more
so during this pandemic with so many
global inflationary pressures war in
ukraine supply chain snarls covet
measures and a stronger u.s dollar which
makes it more expensive for us to import
that's why the central bank looks at
core inflation stripping out the noise
to get a better handle on the cost of
living the bank account has become a bit
more sophisticated
and it has various ways of trying to
strip out the extreme volatility the
jury's still out on how well core
inflation captures this latest onslaught
of sticker shock the cost of living may
be taking a step in the right direction
but it likely still needs a monetary
policy push we're looking for another 50
basis point increase because again
inflation is still well above target the
bank still wants to corral that a little
bit more there's more data coming on
jobs plus another inflation snapshot
ahead of the central bank's next
interest rate announcement on october
26th they'll give us an even better idea
of how effective the last six months
worth of hikes have been ann gaviola
global news toronto
the war in ukraine has played a
significant role in global inflation and
food security and the issue is taking
center stage at the u.n general assembly
this week world leaders are gathering
for the session for the first time since
the start of the pandemic abigail beeman
is following the session for us from new
york abigail
nithu this is the prime minister's first
time at the general assembly in four
years and things got underway with a
stark warning from the secretary general
our world is in peril
and paralyzed the united nations charter
and the ideals it represents are in
jeopardy
we have a duty to act
and yet we are gridlocked in colossal
global dysfunction guterres is calling
on rich nations to tax oil and gas
companies further using the money to
help countries struggling with food and
energy prices and the effects of climate
change all those topics high on the un's
agenda especially in the context of
global food insecurity made worse by
russia's invasion of ukraine
on the sidelines of the general assembly
the prime minister spoke at a global
food security summit saying canada has
stepped up food production and this year
we're on track for the third largest
wheat crop in our history as the u.n
faces questions about its effectiveness
canada's ambassador bob ray says its
work makes a difference with canada
playing a role finding solutions unless
we can continue to provide some hope
that we're not doing our job i don't
think our job is to describe problems i
think our job is to try to find
solutions trudeau announced nearly two
million dollars as part of the
christchurch call summit to fund tech
against terrorism the christchurch call
pushes to end extremist content online
nitu
abigail beeman in new york thanks
abigail
it's a medical appointment minus the
crowded waiting room coming up why more
people who need to see a doctor are
going virtual
with health care systems across canada
under pressure emergency rooms shutting
down and medical services being cut off
more and more canadians are turning to
virtual care while telehealth models are
not new they became far more widely used
during the pandemic in the last
installment of our series code blue
karen lieberman explores how this
technology is changing the health care
landscape
chef and musician dylan harris is
recovering after a long journey to
receive the right medical care for a
potentially life-threatening condition
i would get these
very short periods where if i would
sneeze or cough i would black out the
pain led harris to the emergency room
but with a backlog of patience and long
wait times as weird as this to say being
at a hospital i was too sick to stay
there and i i just couldn't wait harris
instead logged on to a virtual clinic
and it ended up being
totally life-saving care it was a benign
tumor
encased with a sack of liquid
it was about the size of an egg without
access to family doctors many patients
turned to ers putting further strain on
an already overburdened health care
system the founder of rocketdoctor a
site that virtually connects patients in
need with available doctors sees care
provided online as a lifeline for
canadians including those in rural and
northern communities what we've done is
built a system
that enables licensed
canadian physicians to see patients who
are in the province where they're
licensed to practice medicine
and completely free of charge using your
provincial health insurance to do so
the canadian medical association the
college of family physicians and the
royal college of physicians and surgeons
of canada together formed a virtual care
task force and in these two recent
reports identified barriers to virtual
care like ensuring appropriate online
care services are provided as part of
the publicly funded health system
and calling for a framework for
pan-canadian governance so health
professionals can practice more broadly
across provincial borders we have to
deal with a very complex patchwork of
what you're allowed to do in different
provinces who's allowed to treat who so
there's a lot of rules which i think
made a lot of sense in a different era
which maybe don't make a lot of sense
right now tell me a little bit more
about your headache i wanted to
specifically start
with the click of a button canadians can
now also visit virtual emergency
departments 60 of our patients need no
further care outside of the virtual er
which is a pretty significant proportion
of the patients we see
40 percent some of them need to see
their family physician follow up and
some are sent to the er marking a shift
in how health care is delivered and
potentially easing some of the strain on
the system karen lieberman global news
toronto
ahead why a young woman's death in
police custody has sparked widespread
outrage over iran's laws
you're watching global national
[Music]
security forces in iran are cracking
down as protests spread across the
country following the death of a young
woman while she was in the custody of
the country's morality police 22 year
old masa amini died on friday after
being arrested for allegedly breaking
the country's strict dress codes for
women witnesses say she was beaten as
heather urex west reports amini's death
is once again putting the focus on the
iranian regime's treatment of women
while prompting protests and
condemnation around the world
four days after the death of masa amini
and iran has erupted with rage
this protest in tehran just one of many
across the country
in the western city of mahabad iranians
faced off with police according to a
kurdish rights group five people were
killed after security forces opened fire
on another protest monday
across the country and around the world
people are angry whenever i wanted to
talk about this i get emotional because
this could be me
this could be my daughter this could be
my niece my friends whose
who live there but on friday it was
amini arrested by the country's morality
police while traveling with her family
her crime failing to properly cover her
hair it's just galvanized the entire
nation because of a deep deep sorrow and
fury really about
what's been happening with girls and
women in iran for four decades now
iran's police have said amini died of a
heart attack while in custody though her
father says his daughter had no
underlying health problems there are
reports that miss amini was beaten on
the head with the baton
and her head was banged against the
vehicle by so-called morality police we
are calling for a full and complete
investigation
into the regime's
actions and we deserve explanations but
many activists say the international
community needs to do more to pressure
iran's regime isolate iran from the
international community
for its human rights behavior and also
don't limit the iran issue to just the
nuclear file unfortunately too many
western policy makers think of iran
purely in security terms perhaps
subjects change now as the world
confronts the death of this 22 year old
woman
heather urex west global news
today prime minister justin trudeau
denounced the news of planned
referendums in four russian occupied
regions of ukraine in an effort to break
away and become part of russia the votes
are expected to go moscow's way but in a
tweet trudeau says we will never
recognize them and it's a blatant
violation of international law the
referendums are set to start on friday
in donetsk luhansk hairson and the
partly seized zaparisia regions there
are fears the votes could set the stage
for russian president vladimir putin to
escalate his war as ukraine's resistance
claws back lost territory and moscow
loses ground
here's a taste of what life was like
before russia's war in ukraine today
civilians and kiev queued for hours to
get their hands on some western fast
food mcdonald's reopened three
restaurants in the ukrainian capital for
the first time since russia's invasion
began nearly seven months ago the doors
were only open for delivery but people
were so excited many raced down to
collect their meals from couriers
the commonwealth in question next will
more countries cut ties now that the
queen is gone
ten days of public mourning for the
queen has officially ended and now that
charles is king there are fresh
discussions about the idea of canada
cutting ties with the monarch and
becoming a republic elsewhere leaders of
commonwealth countries have also raised
the possibility of holding referendums
to break away tonight eric sorensen
looks at the state of the commonwealth
and whether the realm could shrink under
the new king
the prime minister of jamaica
as they lined up to offer condolences
some commonwealth prime ministers were
already contemplating a future without
charles as head of state new zealand's
jacinda ardern says she expects her
country will become a republic in her
lifetime and antigua and barbuda's
leader says he expects to hold a
referendum on the question in three
years
this is not an act of hostility
but it is the final step as i said
before to complete that circle of
independence
with the queen's death charles is now
ceremonial head of the commonwealth of
nations mostly former british colonies
now independent democracies the
commonwealth represents two and a half
billion people around the world and it's
growing togo and gabon joined this year
that brings the total to 56 members in
the commonwealth of nations but within
that group there are the commonwealth
realms the uk and just 14 others canada
australia new zealand and some smaller
states in the caribbean and the south
pacific in these countries charles is
the head of state the monarch
ten months ago the realms lost a member
when barbados ended its status as a
constitutional monarchy i think that
will start a domino effect it's really
you know lots of caribbean leaders of
other caribbean states have talked about
becoming republics in the past indeed
protests in jamaica greeted the visit
last spring of prince william and
catherine over britain's role in the
slave trade we must also acknowledge the
wrongs which have shaped our past weeks
before becoming king charles
acknowledged the reluctance of some to
see the crown as head of state
each member's constitutional arrangement
as republic or monarchy
is purely a matter for each member
country to decide king
head of the commonwealth ottawa was
quick to proclaim charles as canada's
king while many including some
indigenous people would end that
relationship the prime minister has made
it clear the crown has this government's
allegiance that's the whole benefit of
the monarchy is it does raise you above
the level of ordinary politics the
monarchy offers us that stability that
we need in our system
to have a king or not even in countries
with the closest relationships to the
monarchy it is a debate that is very
much alive
erik sorensen global news toronto
as the world bids farewell to the queen
our donna friesen reflects on the end of
the second elizabethan era you can read
all about that at global news dot ca
slash global national
and that is global national for this
tuesday night i'm nitu garcia tonight's
york canada is the northern lights in
beaver county alberta we love seeing
your canada please email your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com
thanks for watching and hope to see you
again tomorrow have a great night
[Music]
you